[Music]
foreign there you are watching The Press
preview it is time to see what's making
the headlines with the columnist Carol
Malone and the political editor of the
Liverpool Echo Liam Thorpe welcome to
both of you as ever Let's uh take a look
at the front pages Level Up and Away the
Metro reports on the criticism facing
the Prime Minister for traveling to
Blackpool in a taxpayer-funded RAF plane
the Yorkshire post leads with leveling
up two reporting on Labor's accusation
that money is being funneled to
conservative areas
leveling up also features on the front
of the Guardian the paper also reporting
on the shock resignation of Jacinda
ardern as New Zealand's prime minister
the financial times reports that central
banks are committed to increasing rate
Rises to curb inflation
Britain has turned a corner so now cut
taxes that is the plea from Business
Leaders according to the Daily Mail
the European Union wants starmer to
become the British prime minister that's
according to the eyes front page
the sun leads with the news that actor
Alec Baldwin is facing charges of
involuntary manslaughter over the fatal
shooting of cinematographer Helena
Hutchins
The Daily Star has a story about a bus
driver Elvis impersonator aiming for a
number one single
well I reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us so
let's head straight to Our Guest then
Carol Malone and Liam Thorpe welcome to
both of you
um so leveling up making a couple of the
front pages Liam uh you kick off if you
can with the the Metro will put aside
the jet and the safety belt for a moment
but um how do you think Rishi sunak did
today
oh
well look I mean I I I'm slightly biased
here because I've always thought
leveling up was was a bit of a con
really I think if you've if you've
underfunded and and cut billions out of
local areas local government over the
last 10 years and then you have this
sort of beauty pageant or some describe
it as a kind of Hunger Games where these
councils and and local leaders have to
Scrabble together put these bids in and
and just really hope that they sort of
get the favor of ministers and the
government to get some money towards
some projects
um and and as the Guardians analysis
we'll move on to in a second shows often
this does seem to be decided on a
political basis you know how can it
possibly be leveling up to give 19
million quid to Richie sunax wealthy
constituency Richmond and say not give
any money to a number of deprived areas
in in my area in bootle in Liverpool in
parts of Wirral I don't understand how
that could possibly be anything other
than gerrymandering or Port Barrel
politics it seems a completely perverse
system to me you should be allocating
funds based on an area's need not based
on who the MP is or who they might vote
for and unfortunately on many of these
decisions today it seems to be done on a
political basis that that's taken aside
from you know Richie sunax other issues
around flying and and the issue with the
seat belt on a purely political basis
it's a it's a deeply unfair process and
it will hurt more and more deprived
areas that will be left further and
further behind so yeah in my opinion
it's it's not going well well I mean the
government absolutely denies that but
there does seem to have been a shift in
the definition of what leveling up means
to be fair no one's quite known between
a sort of north south leveling up and a
Let's help all the nations have
opportunity which is the definition that
Rishi sunat gave today Carol but you'd
think you hand out two billion quid and
people would be happy but lots of areas
not because four out of five people
who've put in bids get rejected so
you've got a lot of disappointed people
out there
yeah but it's not over yet those bids
could that could still you know come
good in the end there's always going to
be people who are complaining and if if
you know the fact he has given money to
Tory constituencies he's always going to
give money to Tory areas of course he
was if it turns out that let's not
forget this is a guardian investigation
this is God the guardian looked into
this I'll be happier when I've seen
other reports about what has come out of
this I'll be I'll be much happier about
it and if it is the case that he's given
more tutorial tutorials that he's the
laborers well that's got to be that's
going to put thought right I mean I get
very close when going up to the metro
stuff about the private jets I get
really cross about this because this is
just this this is a kind of this is just
trying to knock down a prime minister
that they don't like and a politician
that they don't like you know of course
the prime minister is going to take
private planes you know there's the fact
that the latest one they're talking
about he went from RAF northward to
Blackpool and it took 41 minutes if he
tried to take a train if the trains
aren't on strike and if he could
possibly get one it'll probably take two
and a half hours if he's in a car it's
could take up to four hours this guy
does a hell of a lot in one day he's got
to accomplish more in a day than most of
us accomplish in a week of course I'm
cool going to take part in place he's
not gay
in for cocktails somewhere he's actually
doing his job he's got a country to fix
and that's exactly what he's trying to
do and this this Petty snittiness about
every time he gets on a private plane it
was the same the other week he went up
to do some uh he went up to meet some
people from the NHS which is what he
should be doing at the moment as the NHS
are going on strike and he was
criticized size for that said it was
nothing but a PR exercise prime
ministers have to do that and they have
to meet the people who they're governing
and I think this is just silly
nitpicking on the part of people who
don't like the Tories
can I just say on that I think that
actually plenty of prime ministers have
have got trains around the country in
the past probably one of the reasons
that he doesn't want to get the train is
because it's because the trains in this
country are an absolute joke
particularly in the north living the
ways where he's now flown twice to in
fact one of his own MPS today Mark
jenkinson actually pointed out that one
of the reasons he probably hasn't got it
is because because he can't get a
working train on the Avanti line because
it's been such an utter disaster it was
a bit of a cell phone really for atori
MP to admit that they have presided over
a complete breakdown of the rail network
in this country which by the way which
he soon made previous promises he made
previous promises
that the strikers just now are
destroying their own industry and you
say they might not be on strike today
but the fact that not doesn't mean the
trains go back to normal a prime
minister can't run his business on on
the vagaries of what Strikers are doing
and the fact the trains are running
right you cannot say he can't take the
private place because the Tories have
run the railway's down the unions are
doing a very good job of that on their
own code Carl I don't know if you've got
any trains in the north over the past
five years but long before this
industrial dispute began the trains have
been an absolute joke it's impossible to
get around on time this is long long
before the strike action never came and
Richie sunak when he was Chancellor was
part of a Manifesto that promised to
upgrade particularly trains here in the
north with Northern Powerhouse rail he's
completely and utterly reneged on that
and so he it's you know it's not
surprising that he wants to fly around
the country because he wouldn't be able
to get anywhere on the trains because
they were joking that's not to do with
the strike action okay well it wasn't
just
Carol it wasn't just slittiness tears
your word about the jet uh there were
questions too about this social social
media clip let's take a look
hi one of my New Year's promises to you
was to grow the economy and today we're
announcing the second round of
allocations from our leveling up fund
and that's about investing in local area
yeah someone eagle-eyed noticed there
was a moving car and no seat belt anyway
it was a brief error of judgment
according to uh to the Prime Minister
Buck now does it need to be looked into
Carol so it really does not you know
there is a fine for that okay so why
haven't they just if that's the case
issue with a fine don't make such a big
deal it doesn't need an investigation
he's already admitted he made an error
of judgment he's making this clip okay
he has to turn towards the person making
the clip you can't do that with the seat
belt on because you can write yourself I
get it's against the law I know it is
and yes he should absolutely pay the
fine but Lancashire police do not need
to waste their time investigating this
this is snittiness on their part get on
with solving crime and charge him
whatever fine it is we're not wearing
the suit built okay well I think
kind of came in as this very supposedly
very slick very good PR operation but he
is prone to quite a few gaffs you
remember obviously him sort of
incorrectly pretending to fill up a a
car with petrol paying not knowing how
to pay with a contactless card and now
this you know these are supposed to be
it's supposed to be a kind of a polished
videos that he does but he is thrown to
a few gaffes as well which is quite
interesting okay but to be fair to him
and yesterday it promised his questions
he did not answer the questions about
ambulance waiting time set by him by
secure stabber but today actually he did
really warm the crowd to be fade given
the millions uh in morecam in Lancashire
did he not Carol just very quickly on
his actual performance today you know
with with with people there asking him
questions a very accomplished
performance by the PM
um yeah well yes I think so he can be
you know Liam says he's always making
gas the guy is human you know he's he's
doing some PR storms and he's actually
not very good at them he shouldn't do
them but you know yeah I think he can be
a very good performer I think he was
today okay show you the front page of
the Guardian now uh Tori areas allocated
more cash from leveling up fund uh but
the picture Story 2 is about Jacinda
ardern as I was driving home the news
came through that she was uh quitting
now it seems to be depends what side of
the political fence you're on on this uh
she was going to lose the election so of
course she's going or didn't she do well
and uh isn't she right to quit while
she's ahead Liam
yeah I'm definitely on the side of I
think she's a been an extremely
important and Powerful World figure and
I think that for me personally um at a
time when the world has lurched further
and further towards populism and
extremism and in some of its leaders
I've always found Jacinda Adam uh stood
out for a kind of calmness composure and
compassion as well you know the pictures
that always stands out for me is her
meeting people
um after the Christchurch attacks and
and her Humanity that she showed there
she speaks really well yet of course you
can you can make a very solid point that
there's a very narrow path to victory
for a labor party in the next election
so I can see why people would say she's
she's getting out early but on the other
hand you know I saw people someone say
today which I thought was a good comment
it's very rare that a politician
actually gets to leave on their own
terms and not in defeat or disgrace so
you know fair play so she's only 42
she's she's already achieved so much she
can go and have a total another career
now and she can be very successful at
that
but Carol you can get you can you you
know why Modern Life for politicians is
totally exhausting you know not least in
a pandemic I know you're probably going
to criticize her attitude through the
pandemic of locking down New Zealand and
so on and closing the borders but cost
of living crisis now sharp Rising
interest rates the Ft saying lower house
prices a rising crime you know no doubt
the health issues that we've got here in
this country as well it's it's an
exhausting slog
well it causes an exhausting slot don't
go and be prime minister if you don't
get the fact it's an exhausting Salon
you know all the left are singing the
Praises of this woman who literally
annexed new zealands and the citizens
for nearly two years during covert she
kept up the ludicrousness of zero covert
until until
2021. you know and I 2021 the country
was coming out of covert there was one
case in Auckland and she shot the whole
country down alive
she kept her people safe she said keep
people alive because coven is right is
rampant in New Zealand now and the
reason she's going and it's a cowardly
thing I think she's gonna get trashed in
the car she's tanking in the polls you
know no politician of her stature leaves
before an election but she's leaving
because she knows she's going to get
absolutely Swift yeah this to me this is
cowardice she's put it she's she's done
what she's done to New Zealand for the
past two or three years the past two
terms sorry and now they have a word for
country's in a mess it's in recession
it's in a minute and she's going before
she has to take accountability for that
okay a lot of people would say she's
authoritarian not not the liberal she
pretends to be yes and of course cover
being rampant after a vaccination
program is not the same as being rampant
before people get a jab but we move on
or back to the guardian and Alec Baldwin
uh charged over this death on a film set
um he's not alone in facing charges um
but uh you know it'd be fascinating what
happens in this case uh Liam and also
how it might change what happens on film
sets too
yeah it absolutely shocking case of
course that happened in in 2021 and
shocked the world when it did it's it's
gone on for a long time it's kind of the
legal cases as ebden flowed it looked at
one point like Alec Baldwin was not
going to be charged and and now this
news coming out of America is that is
that he and several others on set May
face this involuntary manslaughter
charges it's important to mention that
um America has obviously very different
laws um to us and I was trying to sort
of get my head around some of it earlier
it looks like um uh Baldwin and the
Armory specialist Gutierrez Reid will be
charged under a standard called charged
in the alternative so the jury will
actually decide which charge they go
ahead with
um his lawyers have come out and said
it's it's a travesty that it's it's a
disgrace that he had no idea that there
was a there was a bullet in that gun
that
um that sadly sadly killed um the
cinematographer in such a tragic
circumstance so yes it's obviously you
know he's one of the biggest stars in
Hollywood isn't it so it's a huge story
but there is obviously a tragedy at the
start at the end of it yeah yeah Liam
sorry we're we're running over just to
say the sun which I don't think we can
show you no one is above the law is
there a headline on the Alec Baldwin
case anyway lots more still to come
including history on the front page of
the telegraph NATO allies tell Germany
to stop stalling a deal on tanks for
Ukraine that ammo after this break
[Music]
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me once again the
political editor of the Liverpool Echo
Liam Thorpe and the columnist and
broadcaster Carol Malone welcome back to
both of you um let's go to the front
page of the Delhi Telegraph shall we
stop stalling the tank steel NATO allies
tell Germany and this of course comes
ahead of the Ramstein Air Base meeting
in Germany itself when they try to get
this package of heavy Munitions and
weapons uh agreed and signed off to send
to Ukraine Carol
yeah I mean they're absolutely good on
them but you know shame on Germany this
is one of the the reasons and I hate to
bring brexit into it um because it's not
really bad brexit but you know Britain
was one of the first countries to
actually offer Ukraine help and to send
proper weapons and proper Armory and
we've been doing it all the way along
and we've been having to shove Europe
along with us to make them do it and
they've been very reluctant the whole
time you know Ukraine God knows what
what would have happened to Ukraine if
Britain hadn't right at the very start
sent weapons and then sent tanks and now
we've sent our great big tanks I forgot
what I called but you know they cost
they cost a project we've sent them and
it's only right that the rest of Europe
in the world joins in Biden America said
they're going to help you know and it's
really important out of self-interest of
nothing else that we we you know we make
sure Ukraine win this war because
Ukraine is very next very near to Europe
and you know who knows what people would
do next he has to be defeated and we all
have a duty to help Ukraine defeat
Russia yes and you know Ben Wallace um
said we're not going anywhere he said
that Russia needs to understand that the
purpose now is to push them back out of
Ukraine it's like end games time isn't
it a squadron of main battle tanks as
you said the Challenger twos three
batteries of long-range artillery
armored vehicles thousands of rounds of
ammunition uh Brimstone missiles which
makes the lead for the times as well but
Olaf Schultz the German chancellor has
said they'll only send leopard two tanks
which makes much more sense as they're
in Europe if America donates uh its
equivalent Abrahams from its Arsenal
Abraham's being very heavy the Americans
suggest they can't even go over some of
the bridges in Ukraine and are hard to
ship so uh it's going to be fascinating
at that meeting
um quick very short bit on the eye and
the EU and uh
secure storm at Davos today Liam
yeah I think this is it's very
interesting you know um kirstama is is
has had an interesting relationship when
it comes to the EU he was obviously you
know an architect really of Labor's um
remain position
um going into the last election he's
then he's since said you know
categorically he would not look to
rejoin and he would not look to rejoin
the single Market what he is now trying
to do is he's got a very different path
to the the what many people feel
including me is the disastrous results
of the brexit deal that we have in place
he wants closer relationship closer ties
with your and a closer trading agreement
how he's going to do that out of the
single market and we'll have to we'll
have to see but obviously the noises as
you can see from the front of the eye
there are the EU leaders certainly favor
starmer we've got um
we've got guy files that saying the West
needs to come together around the area
star were mentioned which is stuff
around Science Tech research and
security we've got quotes from a Dutch
MEP saying I cannot wait for starmer so
they obviously want um to be the next
prime minister and have a closer
relationship because it's in
both of you over and after we don't I do
apologize Carol Carol and Liam thank you
back in the moment